CNN's dimmest rube is back on the tube
yeah Don Lemon gets an HR warning then
returns to help CNN have a bad morning
lady hating numb School Don Lemon is set
to return to his low rated morning show
tomorrow after vacationing in Miami
that's him on the left I'm over here
but he proves criminals always return to
the scene of the crime
nearly a week after the derogatory
comments he made about women saw him get
booted from the air in case you forgot
here's a clip of Donnie boy last week
discussing Nikki Haley's presidential
qualifications
Nikki Haley is in a prime sorry when a
woman is considered being a prime in her
20s and 30s and maybe 40s
are you talking about Prime for like
child supporting or
yeah
the effects or Google it Google it
wow he's the only guy alive who can make
Andrew Dice Clay seem like an
enlightened feminist
as part of his return lemon will
reportedly be forced to undergo
sensitivity training oh and then I'll
have to wear a cone for a couple of
weeks after they remove his testicles
God I want to see that I mean his
training but CNN is reportedly already
testing a left a less offensive new show
to replace him I believe we have a clip
good morning and welcome to wake up dead
today's top stories the Easter Bunny
gave me AIDS why my wife is a huge
and how to make a coat from your
favorite pet to the latest we go to my
co-host Sally I'm pregnant with JFK's
baby
oh all right coming up after the break
don't miss our new segment what's manure
smell like plus how to eat your own hair
and don't miss the premiere of robot
penis now I'm going to chug this whole
bottle of Purell
[Music]
yeah
still better than Don Lemon uh Lisa uh
what did you think of his comments and
does he deserve another chance
well I want to be the first to
congratulate Fox and Friends on
continuing to lead cable morning news
for at least the foreseeable future with
dom lemon
um I mean as someone who is also Pastor
Prime I I'm really curious about the
training that he's going to undergo
because if you learn too much then it
goes in the other direction like if he
learns about the signs of menopause and
infrarian Rhythm and then voices it then
I feel like he goes back in the other
direction right that's true the less he
knows the better which I think has been
his guiding principle for most of his
life well I want to preface my response
by saying it's nothing personal he did
steal my office when I left CNN right
true yeah is that technically your
office if you leave he was in there
faster than the Greyhound out of a trap
right and secondly when I had to leave
my own Morning Show in Britain for
suggesting that Meghan Markle isn't
entirely truthful Don said that I was
committing an act of racism which again
slightly pissed me off so I'm not
reveling at all in his own discomfort of
course just to preface secondly I love
that morning sir you just did yeah I
would watch that every morning so would
I I told them to come up with something
awful and they didn't yeah but they they
extraordinary thing about this I thought
I felt was well apart from the training
which it just makes me laugh it's like
he's been on there 17 years how do you
try are they going to retrain him yeah
right yeah it's just completely bizarre
idea um but but also just what he said
The more you think about it the bit that
really got me was the no no seriously
women are only in their Prime in their
20s and 30s Google it yeah that's right
that's if we all go home and we all go
blind me it's don't got a point
wow it's true because most of his
viewers I would imagine and there aren't
that many of them but most of them uh a
lot of them would be women passed by his
criteria from his Googling past their
Prime so so you're not only Annoying all
the women at CNN Christian Amman Paul
Dana Bash all great journalists by his
definition Pastor Brian but most of your
audience you've just told them you not
suck you're past your brain just on
every level this seemed complete Madness
and I don't know how you retrain someone
I want to be that dumb how do you do it
it's true it's true there is a uh
cat we have to also accept that uh he's
kind of an inspiration for an idiot like
if you've made it this far as that's not
true gay black liberal he had he was
bulletproof yep he was bulletproof
that's how he got so far yeah he still
is he's still got a job if you said
something like that I would fire you in
a second
but I can't because you don't work you
don't work for me
all right
um I I just I don't want to see him
trained so much as I want to see him
explain yeah I I want to see him like
what did he mean by that yeah because I
there is of course the stigma of you
know sexual desirability or was he
talking about like being able to have a
baby which Poppy Harlow tried to say
that and then he you know just talked
over her which is why I'm really
interested in the fact that they use the
word continuing to listen he start maybe
um but like what did he Google that
linked presidential and fertile in the
results yeah yeah I don't think that's a
thing that's not a thing he realized
there's never been a pregnant president
yeah see oh yeah I I I I just it's it's
not clear even he never he never even
apologized like to Nikki Haley yeah yeah
he was just like I know a lot of chicks
yeah exactly
yeah I'd like to go back to those chicks
seeing in an awesome really yeah is he
right about that some of his best
friends are women yeah
well first of all anybody who says women
over 51 aren't in their Prime has never
seen my search history listen
allow me to submit this stepmom yeah
allow me to submit to the record
Caliente cougars five
um
but Don Lemon is at least trying to play
good ball because he has at least come
to the realization there's no market for
him if this doesn't work out right you
know what I mean Don Lemon is the
journalism jobs it's like Bill Cosby is
to bartending jobs you know what I mean
I don't doubt somebody'd be hiring but
they'd be sleeping through the interview
if they did glad somebody stuck with
that one yeah I think that's the problem
Pierce made the bigger Point okay it's
not that he should be fired for sexism
if you were going to fire him it's that
he should be fired for stupid yeah you
never want to hear yourself on live
television saying Google it why because
that's what you do when you're losing an
argument in a bar right and you want to
throw them off the scent it's a
confidence scheme no no I'm right bro
Google it anyway who wants another shot
that's what he found himself doing
idiotic what if his training is just to
watch MILF Manor oh I mean great I
watched five episodes of that last night
they are not slowing down
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else